[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here all right
so there is something that got cut from
my samsung galaxy fold unboxing video
the last video from the other day
but you've probably already seen it by
now all over mostly twitter it all sort
of unfolded
unfolded at the same time
several galaxy folds all broke in the
hands of reviewers
all around the same time for separate
but very related reasons
mine was one of them so this
is the galaxy fold breaks explained so
three days ago when i shot that unboxing
i noticed what appeared to be a screen
protector on the galaxy fold and you
guys already known this anytime there's
a film on the screen out the box whether
i'm on camera or not i take the plastic
off if it's an apple phone a samsung
phone whatever i take off the
pre-installed screen protector you guys
have seen this before so on this phone
there was what looked like this thin lip
all the way around the inside screen
just like your typical pre-installed
screen protector in fact just for a
visual since galaxy s10 sort of had a
similar experience also from samsung
this is a brand new galaxy s10 fresh out
the box and it has this pre-installed
plastic that basically looks exactly the
same it has a lip basically all the way
around and it's got a cutout around the
hole punch display similar look i would
immediately take that off so when i saw
the same lip on the galaxy fold i was
like all right let me add that to the
unboxing video i'll remove that and i'll
just take it off so i pointed a camera
at it and i started peeling from that
bottom where it's easiest to take a
fingernail under the screen protector so
i start peeling it up and within a
couple seconds you start to realize like
it's a little it's more well glued than
a normal screen protector
um and then by the time i get to an area
the size of like a dime in like five
seconds the whole screen just goes black
and then like this little area
there's like a stripe and then the top
left corner starts flickering
uh
that's definitely not good i'm like i
really just broke it like i feel like
such an idiot and i kind of regret that
i didn't get to keep that footage
because it's on camera literally as i'm
peeling it the screen goes black
um
yeah that was clearly not just a regular
screen protector so i emailed samsung
they seemed totally understanding of it
which is interesting but then they
replace the phone so this is my
replacement galaxy fold that i'm
definitely
not trying to peel the screen protector
off of so i set the new phone up it's
all good been using it since but then
sure enough yesterday i see a tweet from
dieter from the verge
my galaxy fold screen broke after just a
day and this whole article explaining it
and i'm like whoa
really and then i see sure enough on my
timeline like all next to each other in
a row within minutes are other reviewers
with a galaxy fold saying hey my screen
broke too oh yeah my screen broke too
mine too all next to each other so i'm
reading this all thinking oh i didn't
realize that i wasn't the only one but
now we have all the information about
the couple galaxy folds that had
problems so of the four galaxy folds
that broke in the last two days
these are the reasons why they broke so
the first one deters he never messed
with the film on the display but it did
start to develop this bulge for some
unknown reason like something got under
the film somehow and that bulge
eventually a day later killed the screen
giving it these stuck pixels then number
two steve kovach he also didn't mess
with the film but i look at the photos
that he sent before he's sending the
phone back to samsung and it doesn't
look fully intact so it might have taken
some damage somehow but either way it
clearly did not survive and it looks
like half the display is going
completely insane then number three mark
germans he actually tweeted the phone
comes with this layer that he thought
was a protective film he peeled the
entire thing off so it must have
survived that peeling but that did
pretty quickly cause the death of the
screen which slowly over the next 12
hours went from half black to two-thirds
black to completely busted and then mine
i got a few seconds into peeling off
what i thought was that screen protector
and then very decisively that is exactly
what broke the screen so that's two of
different types of breaks the way i see
it the first two from actually peeling
at the film and the other two from just
damaging the screen or the film somehow
through regular use
which it's those second two that are
much more concerning but just as far as
the film goes like that's
that's gonna happen people psa if you
are one of the few thousand people
however many pre-ordered the galaxy fold
do not remove that protective film it
might as well be basically part of the
screen matter of fact dez from t-mobile
tweeted this photo uh that started
making the rounds which is clearly a
warning where it says on the plastic of
the fold it says the main screen
includes a special protective layer
peeling that protective layer or using
any adhesives on the main screen such as
a screen protector or stickers may cause
damage i mean it should say will
definitely cause a lot of damage and may
possibly break the whole thing but
anyway the only problem with this
warning is it must be a t-mobile or
carrier-related late edition because
this text is not on the packaging of any
of the review units i went around asking
other people who'd unboxed a fold if
they'd had any sort of warning in their
box you can go back and look at my
unboxing video there's definitely no
text on that film you can also watch
lou's video he did an unboxing there's
no text on that film uh joanna also
confirmed she didn't have any mark
soldier knows best didn't have any
either this is actually my galaxy fold
wrapper
no text at all on mine which means
sometime between them giving these
review units and them arriving in
carrier stores someone must have
realized that they should probably put a
warning somewhere and i think now
they're realizing that warning should
probably be even bigger because nobody
really reads that fine print but here's
the thing even if i never tried to peel
it off a film with a lip like this is
eventually gonna start to collect a
little bit of dust and may even start to
peel matter of fact joanna's as she's
tweeted a photo of has already started
to this is her galaxy fold that she's
somehow managed to resist the urge to
peel but the scariest part is even if
you don't mess with that film at all
there is still a potential for it to get
damaged somehow through regular use so
samsung seeing all this in the last like
48 hours put out a statement we don't
really learn much from it but they did
anyway they said we received a few
reports regarding the main display on
the samples provided we will thoroughly
inspect those units in person to
determine the cause of the matter that's
definitely for the ones that weren't
obviously because of the peeling of the
film but then separately a few reviewers
reported having removed the top layer of
the display causing damage to the screen
the main display on the galaxy fold
features a top protective layer which is
part of the display structure designed
to protect the screen from unintentional
scratches removing the protective layer
or adding adhesive to the main display
may cause damage so we will ensure this
information is clearly delivered to our
customers so essentially that's it a
folding phone requires a plastic display
instead of glass and that soft plastic
is the culprit here like i'm gonna guess
like scratches at a level three with
deeper grooves at a level four if you
know what i'm saying but this is brutal
as far as pr goes not just for samsung
but for folding phones in general like
even i am now way more skeptical about
huawei mate x which i thought looked
incredible but now i'm kind of concerned
about that folding display being on the
outside how is that going to hold up in
the hands of normal people so it is
pretty sad that it's it's going to take
a ding out of how people think about
these phones now to be super clear i was
never really going to go out and
recommend people buy the 2 dollar galaxy
fold i i don't think most people would
but there is still always lots of room
to be optimistic like if you're a fan of
tech you root for this stuff like you
want to see things these crazy new ideas
actually succeed and gain traction so
that we can see a second generation and
a third generation and then it can
actually improve one of the more common
comments i've seen actually is people
saying
samsung they should have waited and
worked on this more until it was done
and ready instead of rushing to try to
be the first foldable phone but the
reality is samsung's been working on
this for a long time they've said eight
years of development so you can only
imagine how crazy this was before in
prototype form so this is the point that
they got to where they felt like
all right it is ready but failures
happen in all kinds of ways and all
kinds of scales with all sorts of tech
products i mean everything from
butterfly keys to wireless chargers to
exploding phones and everything in
between it's just brutal when it happens
to a product that you're really excited
about though i guess you don't have to
say this is a failure yet because as far
as i know they're not delaying this at
all they're still going to ship galaxy
fold in this first generation very much
feels like this like public beta test as
we learned so much from it but that's
our job as reviewers is to give this
feedback and when it's in the public
hands we're going to learn even more
things from it but i think the main
takeaway right now is
we have foldable phones this one it's a
delicate phone the 200 000 folds from a
robot don't necessarily translate to a
lifetime of use by a human there's a
thing called user error and it's gonna
happen there's moving parts there's a
hinge there's a no water resistance like
there's all sorts of new things to
consider with a new form factor and this
is definitely a hurdle on the way
towards them getting good like a pretty
big hurdle but that's the thing is i
still can't wait to genuinely say like
in a future video in some like 2023
video where i can say hey folding phones
are getting really good like that's the
thing you root for in tech is for things
to get good and i still think i'm
rooting for folding phones to eventually
get good but with where tech's at now we
got some hurdles but that's pretty much
it that's where we're at that's all the
information about the couple of broken
galaxy folds that existed in the world
in the first couple days and what it
means but let me know what you guys
still think i'm going to keep using this
phone as my daily driver in the next
couple days for a full review and it's
still going to be a pretty interesting
experience but let me know what you
think maybe you'd still be interested
in a galaxy fold drop it in the comments
section below either way
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace